this is what Italy's next government
could look like if the polls are
accurate
but it's really all about Georgia
Maloney
we will build a solid cohesive
government with a strong popular mandate
which will remain in power for five
years
her right-wing party Brothers of Italy
is ahead in the polls indicating she
could well become Italy's first female
prime minister and the first far-right
leader since Benito Mussolini's rise to
power here 100 years ago
Maloney supporters gathered in Rome's
Piazza del popolo for the last rally
before the elections I give my support
to this party because I love my country
and Georgia Meloni will protect it she
will make laws to protect our youth our
ports and the quality of life of
Italians who do deserve this finally
first of all we need to regain a
national identity that has been set
aside for the good of Europe but this is
not a real Europe because we have lost
our own identity
on the center left the Democratic party
led by the former prime minister enri
Coletta is polling second but Italy's
coalition-focused politics means the
numbers are not in his favor
Abu Bakr sumahoro is part of that
Coalition he came to Italy as a student
from the Ivory Coast in 1999 and is now
running as a candidate
the first thing to worry about are the
high balls and that all Italian families
have a hot meal on the table this is why
we will bring the values of anti-fascism
and anti-racism not to protect Italy
alone but to project Italy towards the
Europe of Rights and dignity
the snap election follows the
resignation of technocrat prime minister
Mario draghi in July internal politics
brought an end to his Unity government
that spanned from left to right and one
that Maloney and her party never joined
successive governments have collapsed
elections are not the solution elections
are the confirmation of a deep crisis of
the political system we win these are
key elections because
I think they are going to close
a season a season in which
the left overall governing Italy what
will the far-right victory mean for
relations with Europe for immigration
policies for the economy
Italy is struggling with soaring energy
bills inflation and an all-round
increased cost of living that will need
to be addressed immediately
Saturday will be a so-called Day of
Silence ahead of Sunday's election and
by the early hours of Monday morning
Italians could know what their next
government may look like they're 68th in
76 years Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera